suppose you checked your inbox tomorrow
morning and you get this email dear
Peter I've been selling annuities for 20
years I'm totally bored I came to this
town to be a screenwriter I want to quit
my job tomorrow and I had this great
script idea happens all the time in fact
one of my interns right now is a
multi-millionaire he's from another
country he just came here three months
ago cuz he said what i want to do with
the rest of my life I've got all the
money I want I want to learn how to tell
a Hollywood story happens all the time I
say welcome come on here's how it's done
here's the form i have people from big
law firms in New York all the time going
I'm sick of being a lawyer I want to
come out there and and and how do i do
it because everybody who has a passion
to tell a story can wind up here this is
what makes Hollywood what it is we're
losing physical production in this state
because the political structure so
stupid but the intellectual brain trust
of story here in la is amazing you come
out here still this is still the land of
opportunities if you want to tell story
look we make almost eighty percent of
every dollar that is sold in
entertainment in the world today why why
does hollywood make eighty cents of
every dollar soul of filmed
entertainment in the world today why
i'll tell you why because we tell the
story of a wounded hero with a chance to
change they don't do it in Europe in
France you know you live you die your
life's over boom your bully brains out
that he's auto BP in an alley we are
dead but in America we still believe in
this hero's journey this wounded hero
who can redeem himself by going
somewhere else and that's why we sell
all over the world that's why they don't
love us they don't love America God
knows they don't they love our stories
and that's because we understand this
myth that is every culture of the world
that guy standing out on his deck when
he's 16 going I gotta get out here
I gotta go somewhere and be something
different that's what we celebrate
that's why we're still powerful that's
why our stories sell so come here come
to LA this is the place to be I mean
it's it's cool why not I came here
that's what I did it's still that
opportunity for people and if they're
not a millionaire have a good savings
most of my other interns aren't
millionaire it's at author there are
people work in other jobs and and they
just want to learn stories so yeah I
mean you don't have to come here
physically but you do have to learn what
Hollywood does however that isn't
luckily you can just watch a lot of
movies and you can just see how it's
done watch the people you love watch the
movie over I'm no smarter than you about
movies all I did is get obsessed I'll
watch a movie 40 times and at the end of
that 40 times I guarantee if you do that
you're going to be a genius you're going
to say look what he does here Luca do is
here you know at how movies work one of
the things I do is I have movie nights
where I just say hey you love Pope
fiction all comment would come on in
will view the movie together I stop it
whenever I want I say look what he does
here look how he does it look how he
puts ticking clocks in every scene look
how we got the hero's journey look how
Jules isn't here he's an old testament
hero look the bullets missed him it's a
miracle and everybody learns by the end
of the movie how Tarantino did it that's
how Tarantino learned he was a kid
sitting at home watching movies
obsessively this is how you learn you're
not a genius you just are obsessed
you